اتحول اليك المعتز بالله حسن في انقره
الينا وصلت عمليه فرز الاصوات في في انقره
بالتوازي مع عمليه فرز الاصوات في عموم
تركيا نحن نتحدث الان عن اكثر من
82% من اصوات العاصمه انقره هي فرزت بحسب
النتائج غير الرسميه لكن اخطر ما يمكن ان
يواجه
عمليه الفرز اليوم هي موضوع التشكيك بين
انصار التحالفين في هذه النتائج انصار
المعارضه يقولون ان هذه النتائج التي
تعلنها
وكاله انباء الاناضول هي نتائج غير صحيحه
يشككون بهذه النتائج ويقولون انهم متقدمون
في المقلب الاخر يقول انصار تحالف الجمهور
ان المعارضه هي تقول انها متقدمه وهذه
الارقام هي ارقام غير صحيحه ويجب الاعتماد
على الارقام الرسميه الارقام الرسميه هي
ما يعلنه
رئيس المجلس الاعلى للانتخابات رئيس
المجلس الاعلى للانتخارات تحدث قبل قليل
وقال ان المفوضيه الى نظامها حتى الان ما
يقارب 47% فقط من الاصوات واثني عشره
بالمئه من اصوات الخارج وبالتالي هناك فرق
بينما يعلن على وسائل الاعلام وما يعلن في
الوكالات عن نسبه الفرس وما تقول يقول
المجلس الاعلى للانتخابات انه قام بفرزه
المصدر الاخير والحقيقي لهذه النتائج
سيكون المجلس لاعلى الانتخابات لكن دعني
اذكر نقطه اخرى ايضا تفضل
جلال انقره واسطنبول كما تحدث في السابق
هي تقول ان هناك جوله ثانيه الى الان
الوضع ما زال هو نفسه في انقره ان اصوات
التحالف التحالفين هي تقريبا متشابهه جدا
في العاصمه